the US is removing China from a list of
countries it accuses of manipulating
their currencies it's happening just
days before they're expected to sign the
first stage of a trade deal
US President Donald Trump has long
accused China of keeping the one at low
levels to get an unfair trade advantage
Alan Fisher is in Washington and tells
us what this could mean for the trade
war go back four years Donald Trump when
he was campaigning to become president
said that in his first day in the White
House he would declare China to be a
currency manipulator well he eventually
got around to it but it was just five
months ago now it really was a symbolic
gesture it didn't really have much
impact it could have opened China up to
greater scrutiny from the International
Monetary Fund but it didn't really
happen this was at the height of Donald
Trump's trade war you'll remember he
imposed tariffs on billions of dollars
worth of Chinese goods he said that
China was pouring billions of dollars in
fees into the US Treasury in fact if you
look at a report that came out just last
week it said that 100% of the cost of
tariffs was being borne by American
families one survey said
American families were about eight
hundred dollars a year worse off so this
shows that things between China and the
United States are getting better and the
markets have responded well to that it's
up again in the United States at the
close of business on Monday so it seems
as if things are improving but there is
criticism of Donald Trump not
surprisingly it comes from the Democrats
Chuck Schumer is the leader of the
Democrats in the Senate he said look
China is still a currency manipulator
the United States shouldn't be taking
that tab away and it says we're giving
away a lot and not getting a lot in
return calling into question whether or
not Donald Trump really is the great
negotiator that he says he is Katrina Yu
is in Beijing and she has more on the
reaction there one way to describe it is
that China in the US had a rocky stormy
relationship and this
this currency manipulator announcement
this phase one trade deal is one bright
spot it's a break in the rain it's a
break in the lightning in the storm but
this is not the short answer is no this
is not the end to the trade one here the
state media and what we're reading
analysts here also believe that this
trade war is going to last for months if
not years because we've seen that you
know these trade talks have been going
on we've had more than a dozen talks
between Chinese and US negotiators and
they almost collapsed last year so we do
get the sense that phase one was really
the low-hanging fruit the things that
the US and China were able to agree on
and that China was able to happily agree
on and everything that they weren't so
sure they basically just push that to
phase two
but phase two they're going to have to
discuss the real things that are really
at the heart of this trade war that are
getting to the US the technology race
for example some structural changes that
China has pretty much we have said know
been very reluctant to change so there
is quite a lot of pessimism as to
whether we will even get to a Phase two
let alone a Phase three but for now I
think China at least the state media
here are focusing on the fact that look
this is not the end but we're still
working on it and that's a good thing so
so far that's that's what we've seen
from Beijing
[Music]